il y avait quand même voir c'est
extrêmement compliqué en en interne du
côté de Berlin pourquoi au juste
il y a un problème politique de
coalition avec les Verts et les libéraux
qui sont beaucoup plus à l'offensive
alors que le Parti social-démocrate a
une histoire de lien de longue date avec
la Russie c'est un peu 50 ans d'os
politiques voilà qui se trouve là posé
sur la table et aujourd'hui il faut
rompre avec ça en plus le chancelier
Olaf scholls lui-même personnellement ne
serait pas favorable à ces livraisons
pour des raisons qui pourraient le le
toucher personnellement il serait
impliqué plus ou moins dans un scandale
financier et une des personnalités qui
auraient des choses à dire sur olaps se
trouverait réfugié en Russie et on
comprend que si jamais on love Schultz
allait trop loin et bien les langues
allaient se délier à Moscou donc ça
pourrait aussi être un frein mais il y a
aussi que encore une fois cette cette
position du qui fait qu'il y a une vraie
réticence et puis quand même aussi les
Allemands vont peut-être donner leur feu
vert à une livraison indirecte via la
Pologne il faut attendre de voir ce
qu'ils vont faire la Pologne qui dispose
d'un certain nombre de ses chars Léopold
II il faudrait que c'est impossible de
livrer normalement c'est cher si Berlin
n'a pas donné en amont son amour de
fabrication allemande mais la Pologne a
l'air de dire que elle pourrait se
passer de l'accord de l'Allemagne et
bâtir une espèce de petite coalition
alors peut-être avec la Finlande qui ont
dispose aussi peut-être avec les pays
baltes s'ils en ont quelques-uns et une
coalition d'alliococcidentaux en quelque
sorte qui proposerait quelque chose à
Kiev qui n'est pas le cas parce que la
crainte des Allemands quand même c'est
aussi de se retrouver seul en première
ligne en quelque sorte avec des chars
lourds uniquement allemand alors les
Britanniques ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
qu'ils allaient livrer 14 chars
challenger 2 mais c'est très peu 14
chars tandis que si les Ukrainiens
disposent de char allemand et uniquement
allemand ce serait les seuls chats
occidentaux impliqués évidemment ça les
embarrasse il y a le pays pour lequel
c'est compliqué aussi on l'a entendu
hier c'est la France Emmanuel Macron qui
dit également qui n'exclut pas la
livraison de chars français enfin le
risque de de glissement dans le conflit
salle préoccupe fortement on voit que le
couple franco-allemand il a du mal à
relancer le moteur sur cette question en
tout cas oui il a du mal à être moteur
c'est le cas de le dire alors les
Français c'est un peu pour des raisons
différentes il y a des raisons un peu
similaires et des raisons différentes la
raison est différente elle est très
pragmatique je peux dire c'est à dire
que il y a beaucoup moins de Charles
Leclerc que de chars léopard 2 qui est
un char plus ancien on estime qu'au
total il y en a environ 2000 de ces
charléopard alors que les chars Leclerc
au maximum on est autour de 400 et ils
sont pas tous en fonctionnement donc il
y a cet aspect là qui fait que pour la
France ce serait difficile parce que
évidemment le char Leclerc c'est un char
qui est très important pour la défense
de la France elle-même et parier
réticent à se séparer d'arme lourdes qui
pourraient éventuellement un jour lui
servir sans parler de peut-être
certaines opérations à l'extérieur et
puis là où les deux pays sont sur une
position commune Paris et Berlin c'est
qu'il craignent en fait que si on fait
ça sans avoir obtenu la garantie de la
part des Ukrainiens qu'ils ne vont pas
bombarder en profondeur le territoire
russe voire même viser des bases en
crimées s'il n'y a pas cette garantie de
la part des Ukrainiens et bien on risque
là d'entrer dans un engrenage qui peut
être extrêmement dangereux c'est à dire
que les Russes estiment qu'ils sont
directement visés sur leur territoire et
à ce moment-là il y a tout le chantage
nucléaire qu'on connaît et donc Paris et
Berlin craignent qu'on parte à ce
moment-là dans une spirale incontrôlable
il faut dire aussi à la décharge des
Allemands que les Américains eux-mêmes
qui fournissent une aide militaire
absolument substantielle ne veulent pas
pour l'instant ils invoquent eux aussi
des problèmes de de
et de maintenance mais ils ne veulent
pas non plus même pour l'instant livrer
des Charlots leurs propres charlour les
chars Abrams donc les Allemands disent
bah écoutez discutons-en entre allier et
mais nous on ne va pas livrer seul les
chars
léopards vous voyez donc que tout ça
crée de la de l'incertitude de la
division parmi les Alliés évidemment
celui qui pour l'instant en profite
c'est Vladimir Poutine voilà il y a une
exposition ce matin
l'Estonie qui vient de répondre après
l'expulsion de son ambassadeur par la
Russie elle expulse elle aussi
l'ambassadeur l'ambassadeur russe l'info
vient de tomber il y a quelques instants
on aura l'occasion là aussi de revenir
merci beaucoup